voir plus haut nous devons a annoncé une
enquête une fois nous devons maintenant
établir la chaîne de responsabilités
nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul dans ça pourrait aussi
actuellement se fracasser et causé un
deuxième déversement de pétrole plus ça
arrive après l'écho du 19 au 20
septembre
hôtelier et touristique est à genoux des
impacts de la catastrophe sur
l'environnement marin mais aussi sur les
populations niveau de la santé vont se
faire ressentir pendant des décennies il
faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe en arabe vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pesci visqueux
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite c'est les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 21 septembre
un autre maison commune est en désordre
ce sont les mots cet après-midi
d'emmanuel macron devant les
représentants des pays de l'onu à
l'occasion des 75 ans de l'organisation
est les chefs d'état se sont succédé par
visioconférence à la veille de
l'assemblée générale son secrétaire
général antonio guterres s plaide lui
pour un multilatéralisme plus fort et
efficace avec de nombreux défis comme
celui de la crise sanitaire du
réchauffement climatique et de nombreux
conflits planétaires
[Musique]
aux etats unis un nouveau juge pour la
cour suprême sera désigné vendredi ou
samedi selon donald trump
hier le candidat démocrate joe biden
accusait le locataire de la maison
blanche d'exercer le pouvoir de manière
brutale en essayant de placer une
nouvelle magistrate avant le scrutin du
3 novembre
deux élus du sénat s'opposent aussi un
remplacement rapide de l'icône féministe
ruth bader ginsburg en france bras de
fer autour de lusine bridgestone de
béthune dans le pas-de-calais pour la
direction la cessation d'activité est la
seule option
le gouvernement lui va mener une contre
expertise indique la ministre délégué à
l'industrie agnès pannier rue nash est
présente sur place avec à la clé un
enjeu de taille éviter la fermeture du
site du géant japonais de pneumatiques
qui emploie 8 163 personnes les
syndicats alice conserver je cite un
petit espoir
venez
l'onu célèbre donc ses 75 ans et pour
l'occasion les représentants de ses
états membres se sont succédé tout
l'après midi pour des discours par
visioconférence crise sanitaire oblige
plusieurs allocutions étaient attendus
notamment celle de donald trump
mais il a laissé sa représentante
s'exprimer à sa place son chef de
cabinet indique d'ailleurs que le
président américain ne sera pas présent
à cette semaine à l'assemblée générale
de l'onu
elle débute officiellement demain le
secrétaire général de l'organisation
antonio goûter rsa lui parler à la
tribune et les conflits et bien d'autres
sujets inquiètent le portugais a écouté
quand même des catastrophes climatiques
pointe à l'horizon la biodiversité
disparaît bon vote la pauvreté gagne du
terrain
aïe la peine se propage diop où les
tensions géopolitiques vont croissantes
et les armes nucléaires ne peuvent être
utilisés à tout nous les technologies et
révolutionnaires ont généré d'immenses
opportunités mais on est également
exposé de nouvelles menaces et la
pandémie de mal à dire que 8,19 a mis en
évidence les fragilités du monde nous ne
pouvons les contrer en oeuvrant ensemble
aujourd'hui nous sommes dotés d'un
surplus de défi multilatéraux et d'un
déficit de solutions multilatérales
emmanuel macron c'est lui ai exprimé
depuis paris et il a alerté sur l'état
de l'organisation pour revenir sur ses
prises de parole on retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter nadège abderrazak
devant l'elysée nadège bonsoir alors que
peut-on retenir de cette prise de parole
du président français
un discours d' emmanuel macron très bref
quatre minutes à peine pré enregistrée à
l'elysée le président français comme la
plupart des 192 autres chefs d'état
membre de l'onu ne va donc pas se
déplacer à new york à l'occasion de la
soixante quinzième assemblée générale de
l'organisation des nations unies qui
s'ouvre donc demain et qui va se
dérouler pour au cours des cinq
prochains jours pas de déplacement aux
états unis comme c'est d'usagé
d'habitude en raison de la crise
sanitaire liée aux copies de 19 le virus
il a jusqu'à présent et bien tué à près
d'un million de personnes à travers la
planète
les nations unies ont su être à la
hauteur des espoirs placés en elle a
déclaré le président de la république
française tout en soulignant un certain
désordre au sein de cette organisation
notre maison commune est en désordre à
l'image de notre monde
ces fondations s'érode ses murs se
lézardent parfois sous les coups de
boutoir de ceux là même qui l'ont
construite des tabous que l'on pensait
inviolable sont levés la guerre
d'annexion usage d'armes chimiques la
détention de masse dans l'impunité des
droits que l'on croyait acquis sont
bafoués et notre système international
prisonniers de nos rivalités n'a plus la
force de sanctionner ces abus à l'heure
où la pandémie nourrit la peur du déclin
le récit de l'impuissance collective
je veux ici le dire très clairement face
à l'urgence sanitaire face au défi
climatique
face au recul des droits c'est ici et
maintenant qu'il faut agir avec ce
qu'ils veulent avec ceux qui le peuvent
en exploitant tous les espaces possibles
de coopération
ces fondations s'érode sous les coups de
boutoir de ceux là même qui l'ont
construite emmanuel macron reste vague
ne cite aucun nom ne cite aucun pays
mais on imagine clairement qu'il vise
donald trump et les etats-unis qui se
sont détachés de l'organisation des
nations unies et de certaines de ses
agences depuis trois ans plus face à
l'urgence sanitaire et climatiques ainsi
que le déclin des droits c'est ici et
maintenant qu'il faut agir a affirmé le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui affirme y croire au
multilatéralisme des actes plus que les
mots en soulignant les efforts fournis
face à la pandémie en europe en afrique
ou encore à l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé
voilà ce que l'on peut retenir de cette
courte allocution d'emmanuel macron pré
enregistrée à l'avancé et diffusée à la
veille de l'ouverture de la soixante
quinzième assemblée générale de
l'organisation des nations unies qui va
donc se dérouler dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles en raison l'a dit de la
crise sanitaire liée au kobus 19 merci
beaucoup
nadège pour toutes ces précisions nadège
abderrazak en direct devant l'elysée
pour aller plus loin pour comprendre la
relation qu'entretiennent l'onu et la
france mais aussi pour pointer les défis
auxquels l'onu est maintenant confronté
nous sommes avec frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste politique jean pierre
guéno historien et puis claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales nous rejoindra également
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer je vais me tourner vers
l'éditorialiste politique frédéric saint
clair notre maison commune est en
désordre on a entendu un cette alerte du
président français face à l'onu alors
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
posture d'emmanuel macron finalement
c'est assez classique assez attendu une
critique des faibles réalisation d'un
projet multilatéral qu'il affectionne
particulièrement mais dont on a vu au
cours de différents moments de sa
politique que lui même prenait le
faisait le choix de 102 s'en abstraire
les interventions par exemple en syrie
armés se sont faites en dehors du cadre
de l'onu en dehors du cadre multilatéral
donc en fin de compte ce
multilatéralisme est une belle idée
emmanuel macron comme l'ensemble des
présidents qui vont se déplacer à l'onu
vont vanté cette belle idée parce qu'on
sait pas faire autrement aujourd'hui
mais dans la pratique c'est une idée
extrêmement difficile à mettre en oeuvre
alors jean pierre guéno j'appelle vous
êtes historien ces mots notre maison
commune est en deuil et en désordre
c'est une formule finalement qui
ressemble un peu à celle utilisée par
jacques chirac en 2002 on l'écouté puis
vous réagissez ensuite notre maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
nature mais pile est surexploité ne
parvient plus à se reconstituer et nous
refusons de l'admettre
voilà notre maison brûle au sujet de
l'urgence climatique jean pierre guéno
est-ce que emmanuel macron marche dans
les pas de jacques chirac
en ce qui concerne sa relation avec
l'onu on est surtout dans une situation
paradoxale si on si on va rechercher
l'origine de tout ça
au tout départ 15 ans après la création
de l'onu et choses semblaient mal partis
avec la france tout le monde a en tête
le fameux machin qui avait servi et
quand charles de gaulle a désigné le
temps à nantes en 1960
quatre ans plus tard de gaulle avait
totalement changé d'avis parce qu'il
avait compris que l'ol lui pouvait être
quelque chose de très positif pour
lutter contre les les dominants contre
ceux qui semblaient dangereux la france
un privilège énorme il ya 193 membres
qui appartiennent à l'oeil nu
aujourd'hui il n'y a que cinq membres
permanents dont la france à côté de ces
géants que sont les états unis l'ex
union soviétique
la chine et la grande bretagne
c'est incroyable parce que la france
pourrait paraître lilliputienne par
comparaison avec les mastodontes dont on
a parlé surtout les etats-unis la chine
et la russie
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
justement qu'aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron comme pour chirac comme pour deux
boules dans sa deuxième à partir de 64
l'ol lui est devenu un moyen
de retrouver un équilibre grâce à tous
les autres pays qui l'ont rejoint
d'éviter des situations frontale
d'éviter de faire que le la géostratégie
du monde soit le monopole des
mastodontes ou des blocs longtemps les
états unis l'union soviétique
aujourd'hui les états unis la chine avec
une posture aujourd'hui à cause de ou
grâce à donald trump tout à fait étrange
vis-à-vis des des principaux problèmes
critiques qui nous guette
on peut les rappeler rapidement
l'évolution des technologies numériques
évolution de la violence
l'accroissement des inégalités la crise
climatique
l'évolution démographique et puis la
perle sur le gâteau aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire
voilà donc c'est tout à fait intéressant
de voir cette tendance qui fait que
l'eau est lui qui nous a gênés quand
nous étions en pleine phase
décolonisation avec algérie dont nous
refusions l'action lorsqu ils envoyaient
des casques bleus au congo dans la
sphère qui concernait les belges et bien
l'eau et lui est devenu un levier que tu
utilises ont tous autres bancs dans
cette lignée qui va de de gaulle
deuxième tendance à emmanuel macron en
passant par jacques chirac alors claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales nous a également rejoint
pour apporter son éclairage claude
blanche maison merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france or votre rue
gassion votre réaction pardon vous
également la prise de parole des manuels
macron ce discours était aussi tourné en
faveur du multilatéralisme est ce que
vous y avez vu une pique envers les
états unis
oui bien sûr c'est une pique envers les
je crois que pour poursuivre ce que vit
fikin d'être dit sur votre avec vos
intervenants
je pense qu'on peut dire que la france a
pu utiliser et peut encore utiliser
l'organisation des nations unies comme
un moyen de
relais de relayer son influence et elle
a souvent fait notamment avec des pays
qui votait dans le même sens qu'elle
alors souvent on a un petit peu critiqué
le fait qu'un certain nombre de pays
d'afrique de l'ouest avaient pour
habitude de voter avec la france mais
c'est vrai que la france a des relais
d'influencé à travers l'organisation des
nations unies par ailleurs évidemment
comme ça vient d'être dit elle est l'un
des cinq membres permanents
c'était la construction de 1945 il n'y
aurait pas eu d'eau nu si on n'avait pas
donné le droit de veto à certaines
puissances et notamment au vainqueur de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui ça pose un problème de
gouvernance générale puisque
effectivement d'autres pays sont devenus
puissants doivent exercer toutes les
responsabilités politiques au regard de
leur puissance économique et que ces
pays ne sont pas membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité
donc ça c'est le problème permanent et
d'ailleurs la plupart des membres
permanents se plaisent à répéter à des
pays de ce genre de ce que je viens de
citer comme par exemple le japon comme
par exemple n'a que bien entendu et il
devrait être membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité
sachant pertinemment que cela ne se fera
pas en tout cas pas de sitôt parce qu'il
est toujours un des membres permanents
qui a intérêt à s'y opposer
dans le cas des pays asiatiques la chine
n'a évidemment aucun or aucune envie de
voir un autre pays asiatique devenir
membre permanent
alors le fait que les états unis et
critiqué le multilatéralisme en effet
est très préoccupant pour la france
parce que ce multilatéralisme est peut
être constituer un relais d'influencé
pour un pays qui est aujourd'hui une
puissance moyenne souvient des actions
fortes de la france au sein de l'onu on
a entendu jacques chirac il y à quelques
minutes à à propos de l'urgence qui m a
dit qu on se souvient aussi de dominique
de villepin s'opposant à la guerre en
irak en 2003 aujourd'hui quel est le
poids de la france au sein de
de l'onu frédéric sinclair 1 sur 183
avec les réserves dû au fait qu'il siège
ce pays dans le conseil de sécurité ce
qui veut dire que l'un droit de veto et
donc il peut s'opposer un certain nombre
de décisions
deux exemples premièrement le discours
de 2003 donc j'ai été conseiller de
dominique deville est pas ce n'est pas
remettre en question
premièrement sa pertinence en matière d'
analyse diplomatique et deuxièmement ça
sa stature de diplomates que de dire que
la france s'est refusée à participer et
c'est tout à son honneur
la guerre a eu lieu quand même deuxième
chose 7
cette guerre en réalité avait commencé
en 2001 et en 2001 lorsque les attaques
ont eu lieu contre le world trade center
la résolution était votée dans la nuit
c'est à dire que l'onu s'est mobilisée
immédiatement pour dire on autorise on
valide le principe d'une réponse et
george bush junior a répondu qu' il se
moquait de ce que tout le monde pourrait
penser que les états unis étaient
attaqués et donc eux-mêmes allait
répondre et donc il ya eu un coup de
menton presque méprisant vis-à-vis du
multilatéralisme de l'onu et de
l'ensemble finalement des pays amis en
montrant cette volonté très républicaine
à aux états unis de dire on y va on sort
les musclés et on va frapper donc oui
cette cette instance
l'onu a une importance en droit parce
qu'elle elle est quelque part un horizon
vers lequel les pays doivent le marché
et non elle n'a pas l'importance quand
voudrait qu'elle est parce que le
bilatéralisme ou l'unilatéralisme
dominent encore les relations
internationales sur sur la planète
jean pierre guéno tout au long de ses 75
années est ce que la parole de la france
a évolué est ce qu elle a été plus ou
moins entendu en fonction des périodes
et l'a peut-être fait ea se pervertir
il faut rappeler quelque chose on ne
sait pas où est passé le manuscrit du
petit prince de saint-exupéry
on a retrouvé deux feuillet il ya
quelques années il y en a un qui est
porteur grandement porteur de sens dans
la version définitive du type pince sa
texture rappelle que deux milliards
d'habitants c'est le nombre de terriens
sur sa planète dans les années 40
pourrait tenir sur une île dont il se
contente de donner la taille
et puis dans le brouillon il il
détaillait il y avait tout le monde
parmi ces deux milliards d'habitants
les jeunes les vieux les jaunes les
rouges les blancs les noirs et puis
lille s'est elle engagée landes
alors j'ai adapté la parabole de
saint-exupéry a aujourd'hui nous serons
dans quelques années 8 milliards
d'habitants 8 milliards d'habitants
debout collé serré pourrait tenir sur
une fois et demie l'île de corse
que voulez lire saint-exupéry et c'est
peut-être la voix humaniste que la
france peut porter en tout cas quelle
qu'elle a commencé à porter avec de
gaulle dans sa deuxième manière le monde
la planète n'est pas démographiquement
surpeuplée pas géographiquement
surpeuplé nous sommes socialement
économiquement économiquement surpeuplé
pour deux raisons d'abord le refus du
partage
je rappelle le kg adil personnes qui
embellissent 50 % des richesses de
l'humanité et puis surtout ou à côté de
tout ça le grand gaspillage
le grand gaspillage puisqu'un tiers de
ce que nous produisons de par le monde
passe à la poubelle là il ya une voie
mais on parlait de l'unilatéralisme ou
de bilatéralisme c'est un pays remettent
en question tous les problèmes cruciaux
actuellement le problème climatique
refuse le partage et refusent la théorie
du gaspillage est une certitude
il ya là une voie et si je dis qu'elle a
failli se pervertir c'est que le monde a
été pris
sous le joug de la folie d'un
ultralibéralisme que de gaulle redoutait
beaucoup de gaulle n'était pas anti
libérale il se méfiait des ultralibéraux
qui à ses yeux était aussi dangereux que
les staliniens
alors voilà est ce que la france geri de
certaines tentations peut-être par par
la pandémie par la coc div 19 est-ce
qu'elle va atterrir et poussé le monde à
avoir une vision un peu moins ultra
libérale un peu plus sage un peu plus
humaniste en s'appuyant sur tous les
pays qu'ils évitent cette politique de
blocs cet impérialisme des états unis de
la chine ou de quelques autres que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure alors il ya
aussi quelques bémols la france n'est
pas toujours exemplaire dans sa
politique intérieure et extérieure et
l'onu lui a fait savoir je vous propose
de regarder quelques exemples iron ont
réagi ensuite membre fondateur de
l'organisation internationale la france
ensemble depuis plusieurs années dans le
viseur de l'onu une tendance qui
s'accentue fin 2018 avec l'apparition du
mouvement des gilet jaune et son lot 2
heures hebdomadaires entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre en mars 2019
michelle bachelet la haut commissaire de
l'onu aux droits de l'homme exhortent
alors paris a diligenté une enquête sur
l'usagé excessif de la force lors des
rassemblements
une réclamation qui survient après
l'utilisation régulière du controversé
lbd lors des manifestations est à
l'origine de nombreuses blessures des
mises en garde envers la france qui se
sont répétées depuis plusieurs années en
2016 l'organisation internationale du
travail alertée l'état français sur le
contenu de la loi dit elle comme riz
pour l'institution onusienne la loi
travail provoquerait un affaiblissement
de la liberté syndicale et de la
négociation collective
autre critique qui fait tache au pays
des lumières celle du comité des droits
de l'homme de l'onu pour la loi
d'interdiction du voile intégral en 2018
une mesure qui selon l'instance viole la
liberté de religion
c'est ce même comité qui épinglait déjà
la france en 2014 pour son non respect
de la liberté de circulation aux gens du
voyage sur la politique extérieure de la
france
l'onu se montre également sévère
sur le dossier libyen notamment
l'organisation internationale pointe du
doigt le soutien de la france au
maréchal haftar une décision qui la met
en porte à faux avec l'onu qui reconnaît
l'actuel gouvernement de tripoli côte
blanche maison à ce que ce type de
remontrance peuvent avoir des
répercussions importantes
diplomatiquement
oui vous vous êtes donné un certain
nombre d'exemples que dans lesquels la
france n'a pas un comportement
exemplaire vis-à-vis des règles de l'onu
ou des différentes agences de l'onu
mais quel pays un comportement
exemplaire nous sommes dans le domaine
de la politique c'est à dire du
relativisme de ce qui est possible au
milieu d'un grand nombre de contraintes
est en effet peut-être que la france
respecte
au bout du compte et l'un dans l'autre
plus que nous autres les règles
générales de l'onu
en tout cas on lui un sucre est d'avoir
organisé une grande conférence sur
l'environnement
peut-être que là encore on peut lui
reprocher de ne pas avoir ajouté aux
conclusions de cette conférence de paris
sur l'environnement des moyens de
contrainte pour obliger les états à
éliminer une part donc progressivement
les émissions de co2 enfin qui réchauffe
lequel le climat qui provoquent le
réchauffement climatique mais hélas
aussi c'était l'art du possible est
l'art du possible c'est qu'il n'était
pas possible d'aller plus loin dans les
conclusions de cette conférence
donc cette conférence sur le sur le
réchauffement climatique a montré la
voie à montrer la voie à suivre mais en
effet le contient pas les éléments de
contrainte pour que les états membres
s'y plient et sur beaucoup de sujets
alors la suite sur les droits de l'homme
je pense que sur 193 pays il y en a pas
beaucoup qui pourrait ce que se placer
dans la catégorie des pays exemplaire y
compris dans les très grands pays
européens ou autres
donc là aussi il faut tenir compte des
contraintes politiques des contraintes
politiques du moment
la france a je crois l'un dans l'autre
de très bons rapports avec l'ensemble
des organisations qui constituent le
système des nations unies
que ce soit le comité des droits de
l'homme que ce soit
l'oit et que ce soit l'unesco dont elle
dont elle abrite le siège et pour lequel
elle regrette qu'un certain nombre de
pays soit sorti refuse de financer
effectivement l'un dans l'autre je pense
que la france est plutôt est plutôt un
soutien fidèle des organisations qui
participent de la famille des nations
unies même si sur certains points elle
peut être critiquée elle a tout à fait
accepté je crois ces critiques alors en
tout cas crise sanitaire vous en parliez
à l'instant claude blanchemaison défi
climatique
frédéric sinclair est ce que là comment
la france peut aider loué nu à se
réinventer aujourd'hui comment l'onu
doit se réinventer face à ces nouveaux
défis et puis tous ces conflits un peu
partout aujourd'hui dans la planète
je vais être assez je vais être assez
défaitiste humble donc le modèle de
l'onu ce la société des nations la sdn
qui a été fondée par wilson en 19 à la
sortie de la première guerre mondiale
elle a fait long feu puisqu'elle s'est
effondré au moment où la montée des
fascismes et du nazisme a rendu toute
politique multilatérale impossible l'onu
aujourd'hui est confronté à peu près aux
mêmes problématiques c'est à dire une
intensification des problématiques
climatiques sanitaires mais également de
violence et puis de résurgence également
deux phénomènes identitaires religieux
ex terra qui pervertissent le bien fondé
de l'idéologie sur laquelle l'onu repose
c'est à dire que l'onu est une
organisation bienveillante dans sa façon
de penser et le problème c'est que la
politique des bons sentiments mac y
avait le disait qu'il faut que quelqu'un
qui fait profession d'être bon en toute
chose il faut qu'il s'effondre face à
ceux qui ne sont pas bons et bien
aujourd'hui
l'onu ne s'effondrera pas mais elle est
contrainte de s'agenouiller c'est à dire
que elle est contrainte de céder la
place aux accords bilatéraux aux
relations de puissance et à ce qu'on
appelle en géopolitique le réel
c'est à dire que healy a parfois
nécessité pour des raisons de politique
interne et pour des raisons de
géopolitique de mettre entre parenthèses
un certain nombre de principes qu'on
appelle un peu dans le commentaire
politique vulgairement bien pensants
pour pour faire preuve de réalisme et de
et d'exercer la contrainte nécessaire
sur les pays je pense par exemple à
l'influencé que peuvent avoir certains
nombres d'acteurs dans la région du
moyen-orient sur la le terrorisme en
europe sur l'évolution de la résurgence
islamique en europe et notamment en
france sur l'instrumentalisation donc on
voit bien à quel point ces questions que
sont complexes
la question climatique est exactement la
même on est fait partie comme l'a dit
monsieur blanchemaison des meilleurs
élèves en activant en matière de respect
des normes climatiques
et pourtant on est quand même pointé du
doigt alors que des pays comme la chine
s'assoit dessus lamentablement bien
rigolo il nous reste quelques secondes
le mot de la fin sera pour vous et bien
rappeler l'histoire c'est un français
rené cassin qui en 1948
rédigé le projet de déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
c'est ça qui doit servir de fil rouge et
c'est ça qui peut donner le le sens
auquel il faut s'agripper mais il ya une
préoccupation aujourd'hui il faut
espérer que les grands états n'utilise
pas la pandémie comme le disait
machiavel quand on gouverne les gens par
la peur quand on les tient par la peur
on tient le rab
j'espère que la stratégie actuelle de
tout un tas d'état ne consiste pas à
utiliser la pandémie et la peur pour
éteindre les bougies sociale car si
c'était le cas si on cherche à éteindre
les bougies social que vous allez dire
qu'on est dans le déni et dans ce cas là
les plus grandes catastrophes peuvent se
déclencher un grand merci à tous les
trois nous avoir apporté votre éclairage
ce soir au sujet de l'onu merci à vous
jean pierre guéno je rappelle que vous
êtes historien frédéric saint clair
merci vous êtes éditorialiste politique
et merci à vous claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales et
dans quelques instants nous partir
aux etats unis donald trump veut
désigner un nouveau juge pour la cour
suprême vendredi ou samedi
côté démocrate on n'entend pas vraiment
de cette oreille puis nous parlerons de
lusine bridgestone à béthune dans le pas
de calais après l annonce de la
fermeture du site qui emploie 8 163
personnes
le bras de fer avec la direction a
commencé
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
thiecko politique n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
des lignes aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire france 3 c'est un
cycle de polichinelle je ne crois pas
qu'il appartient la france d les bleus
des problèmes entre ivoiriens
le bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train de briller le prix
il faut demander au régime ivoiris
référence sorte d n'est pas crisper
davantage les positions la tension est
déjà son look vous demandé un report des
scrutins prévus le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les ciconstances paris c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française le décès de la juge
progressiste ruth bader ginsburg au
coeur de l'élection américaine
icône du droit des femmes sa disparition
entraîne une passe d'armes entre donald
trump et le camp démocrate
le président américain souhaite au plus
vite la remplacer par une magistrate
conservatrice alors que le clan bailon
souhaite attendre la nomination du
prochain président les explications de
guillaume fils à 87 ans la juge de la
cour suprême ruth bader ginsburg s'est
éteinte à la suite d'une longue maladie
celle qui est connue à travers les états
unis comme une icône de la cause
féministe se retrouve au coeur de la
campagne américaine bien malgré elle
présent lors d'un meeting en caroline du
nord
donald trump s'est empressé d'annoncer
qu'elle serait rapidement remplacée par
une autre femme il est dit que le
président est censé remplacer le siège
vacant en espace et c'est ce que nous
allons faire
je présenterai le candidat la semaine
prochaine ça sera une femme
une décision qui inquiète fortement les
démocrates qui craignent qu'une cour
conservatrice efface le droit à libé g
et protège davantage la peine de mort
comme l'a expliqué chaque chômeur le
chef des démocrates au sénat
la dernière volonté de ruth bader
ginsburg était qu'elles ne soient pas
remplacés avant les élections
présidentielles elle a dit mon plus
fervents souhait est que je ne sois pas
remplacés jusqu'à ce qu'un nouveau
président soit installé nous croyons en
cela le peuple américain aussi
aujourd'hui un sondage reuters a révélé
que 62% des américains étaient d'accord
avec elle c'est un nombre si élevé que
cela signifie que les démocrates les
républicains les indépendants
conviennent tous ces justes et qu'il
faut respecter le dernier souhait de
rose bader ginsburg qui souhaite ne pas
être remplacé avant que le nouveau
président soit installé le candidat
démocrate à la maison blanche joe biden
a lui aussi réagi
aux souhaits de trump de nominer
rapidement une juge à la cour suprême
il dénonce une politique brutale de la
part du président les peuples de cette
nation sont en train de choisir leur
avenir maintenant forcé cette nomination
en passant par le sénat est juste un
exercice de pouvoir politique brutale en
2016 le chef de file des républicains au
sénat mitch mcconnell avait bloqué le
vote sur la nomination par les
démocrates d'un juge de la cour suprême
arguant qu'il était inapproprié de le
faire en année électorale mais
aujourd'hui il soutient le contraire et
à d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il
soumettrait au vote le nom de tout
candidat présenté par le président
sortant donald trump a annoncé qu'il
désignera vendredi ou samedi un nouveau
juge pour la cour suprême
deux femmes sont en lice amicone bar est
une fervente anti-ivg de 48 ans et
barbara l'agoa une magistrate
latino-américaine de 52 ans
la décision finale appartient cependant
au sénat sur 100 sièges 53 sont détenus
par les républicains deux d'entre eux
ont déjà annoncé leur refus d'élire une
nouvelle juge avant le résultat de la
présidentielle et deux autres sont
indécis à moins de deux mois de la
présidentielle
l'enjeu de cette nomination accapare
désormais toute la campagne et pour en
parler nous sommes avec françois
durpaire historien et spécialiste des
états unis françois durpaire merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors ce débat sur la cour suprême
désigné avant ou après le scrutin
est ce que la question divise les
américains en ce moment oui ça intéresse
effectivement beaucoup les américains je
vous donne un sondage pour le pour que
vous compreniez vraiment à quel point ça
les intéresse
du côté des républicains c'est plus de
65% du côté des démocrates
plus de 60% des électeurs qui disent
c'est un sujet essentiel de la campagne
électorale ça peut paraître exotique un
canton n'est pas américain vous avez vu
qu'aux états unis on peut se faire
tatouer le portrait d'une juge à la cour
suprême
on peut avoir le juge sur un tee shirt
pourquoi parce que ce qui se joue dans
élection présidentielle c'est ce sont
les états unis dans quatre ans et
pendant quatre ans alors que ce qui se
joue dans cette nomination à la cour
suprême
ce sont des générations de décisions qui
vont impacter la société dans tous les
domaines des droits civiques
l'avortement l'écologie et cetera jour à
peine levé 1,6 tant les avis excusez moi
voilà les juges sont nos mamies c'est
bien cela françois durpaire exactement
les juges sont nommés à vie
et si c'est une juge conservatrice qui
est qui remplace une juge très
progressiste l'icône des progressistes
la majorité ce sera six contre trois
c'est une majorité voyez très important
pour les conservateurs et c'est pour ça
que donald trump veut faire passer cette
nomination avant la victoire possible de
dubaï dont je rappelle que joe biden
pour la première fois de la campagne et
à 141 millions de dollars de plus donc
ça veut dire qu'il a une campagne avec
beaucoup de fonds et au niveau des
sondages s'est pas loupé j'ai ce soir de
la discussion
mais il est en avance vraiment partout
ça veut dire que il faut pour les
républicains
et pour les conservateurs avoir cette
nomination très rapidement je donne
juste une indication kavanaugh savait me
49 jours pour nommer ce juge là il faut
qu'en moins de 55 jours la nomination
soit effective
alors pour les républicains on peut
comprendre à la volonté de donald trump
de nommer très rapidement un nouveau
juge néanmoins pour les démocrates
qu'est ce qu'il en est ils veulent
atteint alors trop l'épaule et
démocrates l'exercice
il est trés de la sainte il est de
diviser pour régner de faire en sorte
que les républicains ne s'entend pas ne
soit pas suffisamment uni pour pouvoir
aboutir à une nomination très rapide à
une validation très rapide par le sénat
votre reportage montrer qu' il y a quand
même vraiment une majorité très mince au
sénat et donc est-ce qu'ils ont des
possibilités les démocrates de diviser
ces républicains oui parce que les
républicains et les conservateurs
plus largement sont divisés sur le nom
de la juge vous l'avais dit il ya deux
juges
il yad'un côté barbara
l'agoa mardi par l'agoa elle est
notamment une juriste de l'état de
floride et pourquoi donald trump
voudrait peut-être de l'agoa parce qu'il
voudrait séduire aussi la floride
et vous savez que la floride va avoir un
rôle très important le 3 novembre lui il
est du côté de la présidentielle de son
intérêt et puis il ya amis barrette et
amis barrette et va séduire plus les
conservateurs purs et durs ceux qui sont
notamment contre la contraception et
l'avortement notamment et ça c'est très
important parce que on pense souvent
qu'il ya un bloc conservateur non il ya
des conservateur libertaire qui sont
attachés à notamment le démantèlement de
l'administration fédérale
et puis il ya des conservateurs purs et
durs si vous voulez des puristes
notamment sur les questions de
l'avortement qui sont très très dur et
vous avez deux juges et deux femmes mais
que tout oppose
si ce n'est qu'elles sont toutes les
deux conservatrice mais pas du même bord
et l'a peut-être ça pourrait jouer du
côté des démocrates pour emporter le
morceau c'est à dire décaler cette
nomination a après après janvier
quand il espère que joe biden sera
président des états unis
alors est ce que c'est une juge
conservatrice et est désigné rapidement
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un impact
sur le vote américain
oui très clairement ça galvanise la
campagne la campagne elle était en train
de s'endormir est en train de s'endormir
parce que si vous voulez les sondages
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
joe biden s'est des sondages fait stable
il est très en avance au niveau national
très en avance au niveau local on
attendait à un petit train temps on
attendait juste la surprise peut-être
pendant les débats le premier débat sera
le 29 septembre
et puis là ça bouleverse tout ça ça si
vous voulez aider crise les démocrates
et les républicains pourquoi parce
qu'ils se disent lassés sérieux c'est la
wii le droit à l'avortement pour les
démocrates
ils sont très attachés à cela du côté
des républicains ils se disent si on a
une juge conservatrice si on n'a pas
cette juge conservatrice c'est par
exemple le port d'armes qui pourrait
être remise en cause
donald trump l'a dit la semaine dernière
il a dit si je n'arrive pas
bima juge et bien vous allez pas pouvoir
porter des armes
le deuxième amendement on va le
détricoter évidemment c'est excessif
mais ça montre un peu ce climat là les
américains conscience que c'est pas les
quatre ans qui viennent qui sont en jeu
ce sont des générations de décision de
la cour suprême
alors pour conclure ce sujet au culte
pour l'instant à la question de la
gestion du coronavirus est ce que c'est
bon pour donald trump finalement oui
tout à fait c'est bon pour donner tron
parce que donna truax si vous voulez il
était dans un corner il était dans un
coin c'était compliqué pour lui
le thème du coc u19 compliqué les
américains lui reprochent sa gestion du
copic 19 la question d'économie bon
c'est très compliqué pour lui ça devait
être un atout ça ne l'est pas et puis la
question de la loi et l'or vous avez la
question de l'autorité est bien plus de
la moitié des américains disent jaub
hayden des mieux placés pour régler
cette question là que donne un tram
alors que c'est son thème de campagne
donc là il a trouvé quelque chose et ce
quelque chose c'est un peu pour lui la
fameuse surprise d'octobre qui arrive
cette fois fin septembre
et bien c'est cette question
conservatrice est-ce que je vais avoir
ma je joue pas est ce que les démocrates
bloquer cette nomination et c'est un
moyen pour lui de faire bloc derrière
lui on sait que le corps électoral est
pour l'instant favorable aux démocrates
il veut et l'épuisé sa base et faire en
sorte et bien que de renverser
l'élection son côté toute nouvelle pour
lui toute surprise va évidemment dans le
camp de celui qui aujourd'hui la
outsiders et donald trump pour l'instant
hélas outsiders de cette élection de
cette potentielle réélection merci
beaucoup françois durpaire pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
historien spécialiste des états unis et
puis on en france l' usine de pneus
bridgestone située à béthune dans le
pas-de-calais fermera bien ses portes
malgré la réunion de crise qui a eu lieu
cet après-midi de quoi contrarier
salariés élus locaux et syndicats qui ne
perdent pas espoir
face à l'incompréhension générale le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'il n'en avait
pas terminé avec le fabricant les
précise
en syrie elle benavides bulbul lyon au
terme d'une réunion de crise de plus de
deux heures syndicats élus locaux
ministre qui se sont rendus au chevet de
bridgestone à béthune sorte et la
sentence tombe bridgestone à étudier
toutes les solutions alternatives
possibles notamment celle de nouveaux
investissements pour une production de
pneus différents à béthune le projet de
cessation totale d'activité est
toutefois la seule option qui
permettrait de répondre à la surcapacité
de production structurelle de bridgetown
et donc de sauvegarder la compétitivité
de ses opérations en europe
si le fabricant japonais assure qu un
plan d'accompagnement se réadapter à
chaque salarié
d'ici cinq mois maximum pour le moment
c'est au total 8 163 emplois qui sont
menacés mais les employés de béthune en
ont pas terminé avec l'entreprise
soutenu par les ministres
ils nous ont dit qu'ils avaient examiné
un certain nombre de scénarios nous
voulons les contre expertises et nous
allons mandater un cabinet conseil
accenture qui va faire ce travail et qui
connaît bien le marché du pneu
automobile et qui nous permettra non
seulement de regarder ce scénario mais
également de proposer éventuellement de
soumettre des scénarios alternatifs et
pour cause l'entreprise de pneumatiques
avait touché ces dernières années des
subventions régionales nationale et même
européenne allant jusqu'à 2 millions
d'euros des sommes qui étaient destinés
à l'investissement dénoncent les
syndicats une histoire qui rappelle
étrangement celle de l' usine de
sèche-linge jouir poule à amiens ce en
2017 qui avait laissé quelques 250
emplois sur le carreau et pour en parler
nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes alexis poulain heureux de
vous retrouver en direct sur rt france
alors la direction
se montre inflexible l'hôte de l'état
obtient cinq mois de négociations pour
éviter la fermeture que peut-on attendre
est ce que le dialogue social est déjà
rompu
oui le dialogue social est largement
plus on al'âge simplement un théâtre
triste où les politiques
systématiquement sont aux portes de
l'usiné quand elles ferment ils sont là
quand elle ouvre quand il donne de
l'argent à des multinationales qui ne
m'ont pas besoin et ils sont là quand
elle ferme pour faire croire qu'ils ont
encore un pouvoir
ça fait longtemps que c'est le même
cirque ce tragique pour les salariés
pour les employés qui eux veulent sauver
leurs emplois
on a eu les continental on a eu
bridgestone world poule vous en parliez
on a eu d'autres fabricants de pneus
tout ça n'arrête pas tout simplement
parce que c'est la mondialisation que
l'emploi quand il dépend d'une
entreprise internationale il est
extrêmement volatile le problème c'est
que ce sont des entreprises qui ont avec
quelle des cabinets de conseil comme
accenture et d'autres qui leur disent ou
investir parce qu'il ya des aides de
l'état dont qu'elle vienne en disant que
bien sûr elles sont là pour le long
terme qu'elles vont s'investir dans la
région qu'elles vont aider à créer un
bassin d'emploi et puis quand la
conjoncture va changer donc en
l'occurrence crise du coronavirus baisse
de la croissance baisse de l'achat de
deux voitures
eh bien elles disent qu'elles ne peuvent
pas soutenir les activités elles ne
rendent pas l'argent bien entendu en
revanche elle mettre tout le monde
dehors
et puis elles continuent leurs activités
sur le territoire européen ou ailleurs
en pologne notamment
ça a été le cas pour pourvoir le pouls
pour les continental donc rien ne change
ce qui est sinistre c'est de voir les
politiques toujours là à la manoeuvre
faire croire qu'ils ont un quelconque
pouvoir ils n'ont aucun parce que ça
s'appelle la mondialisation parce que
depuis des années des dizaines d'années
les idéologies dominantes fait que la
mondialisation doit être heureuse et
qu'elle est censée apporter croissance
et emploi c'est vrai une partie du temps
on est rentrés maintenant dans l'autre
côté de la mondialisation où les grandes
entreprises préfèrent aller là où
l'emploi est moins cher sachant que de
toute façon des des cargos entiers de
pneus peuvent venir en europe
ça ne posera aucun problème donc vous
avez deux crises écologiques économiques
qui sont tout à fait liés parce que les
entreprises décident de ne plus produire
sur des territoires et des politiques
qui font semblant de ne pouvoir rien
faire qui font qu'ils ne font rien
d'ailleurs puisque dès que vous leur
demandez de faire des lois
protectionnistes
il n'en faut
kuhn parce que nos grands champions du
cac 40 renault michelin qui fabrique des
pneus eh bien ce sont aussi des
entreprises internationales
michelin ne produit plus de pneus sur le
territoire français ils ont des centres
de recherche et développement
parce que tout simplement ils font comme
les grosses entreprises mondiales
ils choisissent là où l'emploi est le
moins cher en france c'est pas le cas on
a décidé que l'emploi avait appris qu'il
fallait payer les gens correctement et
même correctement parfois c'est pas
assez
et voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
ce n'est que la même scène d'une longue
litanie qu'on aimerait voir s'arrêter
mais malheureusement je vois pas demain
comment ces responsables d'hier qui sont
aujourd'hui au pouvoir pourrait changer
quoi que ce soit c'est à dire que quand
agnès pannier rue nash et se déplace sur
place aujourd'hui quand elle dit que le
gouvernement va mener une contre
expertise pour vous il n'y a pas de
solution derrière n'y a pas
d'alternative finalement c'est plié
non vous avez une alternative réelle
c'est la coopérative c'est ce qu'ont
fait les lip à l'époque un qui
reprennent lusinchi les ouvriers qui
relancent lusine parce qu'ils
connaissent leur métier parce qu'il
sauve les machines et parce qu'ils vont
créer des compétences se former sur le
tas et arriver à quelque chose
laquelle est la réponse de la ministre
c'est cocasse c'est malheureusement
triste mais ça fait sourire c'est de
payer un cabinet de conseil accenture
avec nos impôts
formidable que va faire le cabinet de
conseil eh bien il va dire oui à
peut-être d'autres solutions possibles
mais en quoi cela va sauver les emplois
c'est gagner du temps tout simplement
peut-être gagner même deux ans pour
qu'en 2022
emmanuel macron ne soit pas pris pour
responsable de la fermeture de l'usiné
mais sur le long terme sur le pérenne le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la chine a
le droit d'envoyer des pneus très peu
cher sur le marché européen et que tous
les fournisseurs et bien vont se fournir
là où c'est le moins cher est que nous
ne mettons pas de barrière l'europe qui
protège n'existe pas elle ne protège pas
aux frontières
les lions nous ne faisons rien pour nous
protéger parce que nous avons peur en
fait de la réponse de ses grands marchés
qui pourraient fermer l'entrée des
produits européens sur leur marché que
ce soit les états unis ou la chine
donc l'europe est pieds et poings liés
par rapport à cette mondialisation et
nos emplois industriels
eh bien ils migrent ils migrent vers les
pays où la main d'oeuvre est la moins
chère et pour ça malheureusement les
politiques ne peuvent rien sauf s'il
décide effectivement d'avoir une
politique protectionniste mais ils en
sont loin
et aujourd'hui ce que je vois comme
beaucoup c'est simplement des
gesticulations électoralistes entre 2008
et 2016 l'usiné tu es était sous
perfusion puisque cinq cent mille euros
ont été alloués à l' usine par le
conseil régional des hauts de france
est ce que le gouvernement finalement
s'est emparé du sujet trop tard alors
que 8 163 salariés on le rappelle sont
concernés oui trop tard parce que c'est
une politique de long terme c'est à dire
que ces décennies de croyances
idéologiques dans la mondialisation où
nous avons ouvert grands toutes les
portes du marché français et du marché
européen par par intérêt parce que comme
je le disais nos entreprises ont aussi
besoin des marchés internationaux
ça ne se change pas en quelques mois et
ça ne va pas changer en quelques mois et
que tout cet ancien sur le plan de
relance sur la relocalisation
elle n'a aucun sens sans l'autre pendant
de cette relocalisation c'est à dire le
protectionnisme faire qu'aujourd'hui des
produits produits à l'étranger coûte
plus cher sur nos marchés nationaux
alors là à ce moment là les entreprises
internationales sont obligés d'avoir des
productions locales pour les vendre sur
le marché local mais nous en sommes loin
tout simplement parce que c'est du
donnant donnant et parce que tous les
leaders que nous avons aujourd'hui et
certains commentateurs qui critiquent la
baisse de croissance en disant que si
finalement les usines ferment c'est
parce qu'il ya trop de jeux en vélo et
pas assez de gens qui achètent des
voitures c'est stupide comme pensée
c'est pas du tout ça le problème le
problème c'est que nous ne protégeons
pas nos emplois que nous ne protégeons
pas la production neuve ne faisons plus
de machine à laver sur notre territoire
je rappelle que la suisse a encore deux
usines de machine à laver
c'est un manque de volonté politique est
aujourd'hui et bien c'est simplement
être là parce que les caméras sont là
parce que l'opinion publique sans
lampard mais que va-t-il se passer parce
que là on parle du plan social de
bridgestone mais combien de plans
sociaux vont arriver dans les mois qui
viennent avec la crise économique que
nous vivons
j'attends de voir ce que feront les
politiques à ce moment là merci beaucoup
alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions directes sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes et
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la situation sanitaire en france
avec un nouveau tour de vis à lyon et à
toulouse
puis nous parlerons de l'école nationale
de la magistrature le garde des sceaux
eric dupond-moretti choisi une avocate
pour la diriger c'est la première fois
qu'un magistrat ne sera pas à la tête de
la prestigieuse école de bordeaux resté
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois des images assez touchants
de l'armée qui était presque impliqué
avec les manifestants aujourd'hui on
sent que le ton a changé c'est la cause
d un politique et sont en train de
manipuler l'armée on sait très bien
pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus c'est
pas s'ils savent que c'est leur fin ils
se préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence ils n'en
voient pas très violent mais on va
rester
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
parlement qui vote de grands objectifs
massif à peu à la manière des plans
quinquennaux soviétique le soutien à
l'éolien c'est entre 70 et 90 milliards
d'euros
la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément montech désormais ses financés
par les taxes qu'ils reportent sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des gilet jaune en fait isolé pour faire
de l'écologie
il est honteux c'est difficile
d'expliquer aux gens que on laboure les
fonds marins ont détruit un écosystème
humain économique et tout ça pour le
bien de la planète
[Musique]
la planète terre dans un futur proche
le mend cachons ici un débris spatial
audard f crois qu il touche un satellite
d'un pays mange cela pourrait engendrer
un conflit autour de la terre l'espace
est polluée
il dérive en orbite d'innombrables
débris des millions de fragments de
tailles variées incontrôlable il est
extrêmement difficile de les suivre tous
heureusement les accidents vont se
multiplier les vols habités risque de
devenir trop dangereux et les
communications par satellite vont se
détériorer les systèmes de navigation
gps pourrait devenir de moins en moins
fiables internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse
le gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie
tout cela pourrait devenir totalement
inutilisable
[Musique]
et je peux faire pousser jusqu'à dix
mille pieds de coquins sur un hectare
parce qu'il pousse proches les uns des
autres
beaucoup de gens disent que la coca est
mauvaise mais nos autres paysans qui la
cultiveront pour survivre ne les
traitons pas comme un ennemi
[Musique]
l'oscar les fermiers dans tous les
colombiens sont obligés de détruire les
plantations illégales
la culture de la coca est interdite en
colombie
[Applaudissements]
il envoie l'armée avec des fusils et des
matraques pour déraciner la coca que
nous plantons ok c'est le cas yoann je
ne suis pas un dealer je ne travaille
pour aucun carton je cultive la coca
pour survivre le maintien il ne m'en
réjouis pas cassé
[Musique]
il ya les manouches il ya les danish il
a les sintis et ya les gitans dont on
peut voir on peut voir déjà que on a un
souci au niveau des des roms qui sont mi
2010 on aura atteint les considérer
comme des étrangers et quand est née en
france quoi c'est koné des étrangers de
france
saluons le 15 août hadzic herria et
dynamique
ça ne me faisait plus chaud canaris
canaries c'est une fille région qui
travaillent dur centre et d'arrière
missiles ont abattu mon frère de son
froid dans ma tribu tard le cinéma et
l'entorse
coeur
et les documents
tous les gitans du monde je pense qu'on
est les plus détestés de toute une
communauté riche âge pour de vrai je
pense qu'on devrait le prison
[Musique]
chaque année 150 tonnes de déchets
électroniques sont amenés au ghana
c'est un travail dangereux mais nous
avons besoin d'argent
c'est pourquoi nous continuons à le
faire pour les pays développés
c'est le moyen le plus simple et le
moins coûteux de se débarrasser de ses
déchets toxiques
c'est une bombe à retardement si nous ne
trouvons pas de solution dans les deux
ou trois années à venir ce sera encore
pire et pour les habitants sur place
cette décharge est un aller simple vers
la mort cela veut dire que cette partie
d'accra sera tellement pollué
il faudra normalement poser une clôture
autour du site couler une chape de béton
dessus je vais créer un autre tchernobyl
accra
bon ça y est ici on connaît ses
traditions et ses festivités depuis le
plus jeune âge si tu es né à tout le
québec
tu as de la poudre dans le sang on n'a
pas le goût à la musique
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une petite brûlure mais ce n'est
rien
je ne dirais pas que nous sommes fous
nous sommes juste mexicain nous sommes
nés dans ce pays
[Musique]
c'est notre façon de vivre
quand on tombe amoureux on a des
papillons dans le ventre
ici à tout le québec on dit qu'on a des
feux d'artifice
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face aux plus fiction posent
à nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
un climat particulier en ce moment en
côte d'ivoire et des violences sous
prétexte donc manifestation et
d'expression de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on est si comme m
est-ce que sincèrement vous êtes
certains que le scrutin du 31 octobre
sera maintenu à la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 21 septembre 2001 face au co vide
toulouse et lyon sert à leur tour la vis
dans la capitale des gaules pas plus de
1000 personnes lors d'événements publics
10 lors des réunions privées par exemple
à l'école en revanche c'est un
assouplissement prévue à partir de
demain sur tout le territoire ce qui
devrait limiter le nombre de fermetures
de classes
quant au test salivaire ils sont mis en
place pour raccourcir les files
d'attentes
[Musique]
toujours en france la réforme de l'école
nationale de la magistrature le garde
des sceaux choisi l'avocate nathalie
rhorer à sa tête première femme et
première non magistrats d'être proposé
pour occuper ce poste
favorable à la suppression de
l'institution quand il était avocat eric
dupond-moretti souhaite au contraire
aujourd'hui ouvrir davantage le mm pour
je cite rompre avec des traditions
suranné l annonce a été faite à la
télévision nationale par le chef de la
junte militaire l'ex ministre de la
défense ben dhaou a été désigné
président de transition par un comité
mis en place par la junte au pouvoir
depuis le putsch du 18 août au mali il
doit exercer sa fonction pendant
plusieurs mois avant un retour des
civils au pouvoir
[Musique]
elle la situation sanitaire en france à
présent et les derniers chiffres de
santé public français l'agent s'annonce
5280 18 nouvelles contaminations
qu'ovide 19 ans 24 heures 53 personnes
sont mortes à l'hôpital à 638 patients
en réanimation est liée aux comics 19 et
après bordeaux marseille nice lyon est à
son tour concernée par de nouvelles
mesures la préfecture du rhône vient de
l'annoncer à la limite pour les
événements en extérieur passe de cinq
mille à mille personnes vide greniers
fête foraine interdit obligation de
déclaration pour les rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes et coûté la vie des
lyonnais à ce sujet je pense que j'avais
lamentations sunu vraiment bien même si
c'est sûr que ça restera vraiment là
le fait de sociabiliser avec d'autres
personnes il faut quand même qu'on
respectent les distances qu'on porte le
masque c'est très important je suis
d'accord sur ces mesures
je pense qu'il faut prendre des
précautions et puis ma foi il faut avoir
du bon sens
ah ben tiens le coup jusqu'à nous
voulons donc on
ok cette maladie partira mais pour le
moment nous respectons la loi et ce
qu'ils font vivre
il faut vivre avec la santé et l'entente
avec une maladie comme ça et olivier
ferrand était en déplacement aujourd'hui
à mantes-la-jolie dans les yvelines le
ministre de la santé à visiter un centre
de dépistage du coronavirus et ce alors
que les tests salivaires sont mises en
place pour raccourcir les files
d'attentes
ces dernières s'allonge depuis plusieurs
jours devant les laboratoires nous
mettons le paquet sur la priorisation
des tests selon la sémantique tout à
l'heure d'olivier ferrand focus sur la
stratégie de dépistage avec ce reportage
signé lee la femme ouzou et dounia ciel
vous appelez pour prendre rendez vous
pour faire un test pcr pas de rendez
vous avant deux ou trois semaines des
files d'attentes de plusieurs heures
pour être testés et jusqu'à dix jours de
délai avant d'obtenir les résultats
les laboratoires françaises sont saturés
à la traîne au début de l'épidémie la
france a significativement augmenté sa
capacité de tests pcr désormais plus
d'un million de tests sont réalisés
chaque semaine dans le pays soit environ
15 pour 1000 habitants
une volonté du gouvernement de permettre
au plus grand nombre d'être tc mais la
machine est grippée
les laboratoires n'arrive plus à suivre
dans ce laboratoire situé dans les
hauts-de-seine les jours passent et les
files d'attentes ne diminue pas pour
certains ici le dépistage se révèle être
un véritable parcours du combattant
ma fille est positive qui habitent
souvent toi donc je vais vérifier que je
ne le suis pas pour pouvoir continuer à
travailler et à beaucoup de monde se
trompe c'est mal gérée en fait je suis
né hier et il y avait une queue encore
plus enfin il y avait plus de monde
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont voulu faire
détester ou transmet
pas une organisation les gens sont un
peu débordées bon allez comprendre
bon voilà il faut aller mieux
s'organiser quoi l'analyse des tests et
sans fin et certains laboratoires en
profite
n'hésitant pas à proposer des tests
payant pour donner des résultats plus
rapidement une dérive qui pointe du
doigt la stratégie de test à tout va du
gouvernement et qui l'obligent à un
ajustement
nous sommes confrontés à de réelles
difficultés organisationnelles que nous
devons résoudre c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons instauré une
doctrine de priorisation des tests avec
une liste de personnes prioritaires le
gouvernement à l'affût de nouvelles
alternatives pour accélérer les
diagnostics se félicite de la décision
de la haute autorité de santé
elle devait à l'idée les tests
salivaires moins douloureux moins
dissuasif et surtout plus rapide mais
certains spécialistes exprime déjà
quelques doutes
c'est un pas de plus pour endiguer le
virus mais ça sera pas suffisant nous ce
qu'on souhaiterait c'est que signé des
choses plus plus pragmatiques qu'ils
soient pas mises en place
on aimerait bien avoir des plateformes
par exemple de d'adressage des patients
des plateformes téléphoniques au niveau
départemental que les choses soient un
peu mieux organisées et c'est vrai que
nos équipes et nous-mêmes commençons
être un petit peu fatigué on va dire
autre conséquence de ces délais
d'attenté à rallonge le retard
inévitable dans la prise en charge des
cas contact de personnes diagnostiquées
positive c'est toute la stratégie
sanitaire qui est compromise et l'enjeu
est capital pour l'exécutif il s'agit
d'éviter à tout prix un nouveau
confinement qui aurait des conséquences
désastreuses sur l'économie et pour
parler de la stratégie des tests ou plus
précisément pour parler des tests
salivaires nous sommes avec alexandra
prieux pdg de skills elle bonsoir est
avec vous franck molina directeur de
recherche au cnrs merci à tous les deux
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors femme est avec sandra prieux vous
est intervenu sur notre antenne pour
parler d'un nouveau test de dépistage du
coronavirus il s'appelle isikoff simple
et rapide réalisée par prélèvement
salivaire alors où est ce que vous en
êtes aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est
commercialisé
alors aujourd'hui le test est
commercialisé donc nous avons poursuivi
nos recherches et le test a été marqué
ces oeufs à la fin du mois de juin donc
aujourd'hui le test physique offre est
commercialisée en europe et dans le
reste du monde alors franck molina vous
avez travaillez vous aux côtés du comité
scientifique au printemps dernier avec
telles difficultés vous avez rencontré
pourquoi l'autorisation des tests
salivaires at-elle traîner tout d'abord
j'étais au comité caire donc qui venait
en soutien du conseil scientifique et
qui depuis s'est arrêtée d'ailleurs est
effectivement dans notre vision on
essayait de renforcer la stratégie de
tests avec des tests complémentaires qui
rit un peu plus sur le terrain qu'ils
répondraient un peu plus facile
facilement d'abord en termes
d'acceptation de la population mais
aussi qui donne des réponses plus
rapides donc des tests un peu plus ou
alors alexandre apprieu aujourd'hui donc
votre vos tests sont distribués dans le
monde entier en europe en france à
thèmes tels d'eau sont ils distribués
aujourd'hui pour le moment c'est assez
limité en france c'est vrai que nous
vendons principalement à l'étranger et
c'est lié au fait que la france a donc
voulu faire des tests supplémentaires
pour très sûr et qu'il était important
de travailler sur prélèvement salivaire
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
franck molina finalement ce délai assez
long pour mettre sur le marché un
nouveau test un test salivaire qui même
s'il est peut-être un peu moins fiables
pourrait effectivement désengorger les
laboratoires aujourd'hui comment est ce
que vous le comprenez d'abord un peu la
prudence parce que la nouveauté entre
haine engendre souvent la prudence et
c'est bien normal
on a essayé de faire les choses le plus
vite possible pour répondre à l'urgence
de la première vague et finalement
lorsque le test est sorti on s'est
retrouvé avec des niveaux de validation
très intéressant qui montrait l'utilité
d'un tel test
mais comme alexandra le disaient
certains ont souhaité renforcer et on
peut comprendre c'était cela le problème
c'est que les cas se sont ralenties dans
le sud de la france et ces renforcements
ne pouvais pas te fais ici sur
montpellier donc c'est un petit peu
tardé dans l'été mais en dehors de tout
ça c'était sous la vue sont utilisés
partout sur la planète dans différents
endroits et ont montré leur efficacité
justement on sait qu'il faut les
utiliser assez rapidement en complément
de ce qui existe déjà
justement en termes de fiabilité
alexandre à apprieu qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire avec certitude
aujourd'hui sur ces tests salivaires
alors c'est difficile de parler de
parler de certitude aujourd'hui enfin
plus tôt vendredi donc la chaise a
déclaré qu'il était opportun de
d'utiliser les tests salivaires dans un
certain nombre de dépistages selon bien
sûr nous nous félicitons et souvent nous
sommes bien entendu très heureux et à
côté de cela il ya un certain nombre
d'études au niveau international qui
montre également que les tests
salivaires peuvent être utiles et
peuvent être très efficaces dans un
grand nombre de cas c'est à dire quand
j'ai des symptômes alors là on est sûr à
100% que le test va réagir et eva
indiqué que nous sommes positifs le 100
% fin je pense que franck pour en parler
mieux que moi mais c'est des choses qui
sont toujours délicat à faire en
biologie quel que soit le test
d'ailleurs et quel que soit le
prélèvement mais aujourd'hui oui les
tests salivaires sont des tests qui
peuvent être en effet très performant
pour les personnes symptomatique
et comme nous l'avons vu nous chez nous
et comme d'autres personnes l'ont vu
autre part dans le monde également pour
les personnes asymptomatiques alors
franck molina qui peut le faire
aujourd'hui ce test salivaire
ou est-ce qu'on peut le faire plus
précisément donc aujourd'hui comme on
l'a dit dans différents pays et les gens
le pratiquent déjà
c'est même une d'aucune des doctrines
principal dans plusieurs pays aux états
unis les pratiques et depuis longtemps
en allemagne et maintenant
en angleterre aussi de façon assez
massive en france c'est un petit peu
difficile c'est utilisé de façon très
ponctuelle par quelques utilisateurs
parce que tout le monde attende tout le
monde a la volonté de l'utiliser mais
tout le monde attend ces dernières
autorisations et dont effectivement la
position de la chaise et finalement une
étape une étape pourquoi parce que elle
était associée aussi à des
préconisations d'utilisation sur les
symptomatique et j'aimerais revenir sur
ce point les symptomatique c'est très
bien mais finalement est-ce bien là la
population qui vous visent et qu'il faut
viser lorsque l'on souhaite enrayer la
propagation du virus
aujourd'hui on voit cet engorgement vous
avez décrit tout à l'heure dans votre
sujet et peut-être que la stratégie
serait d'autant plus intéressante
qu'elle cible les personnes susceptibles
de propager le virus et sans le savoir
donc les asymptomatiques sont une
population intéressante où effectivement
les cas contactez aller en ce qui nous
concerne nous on observe des choses très
intéressantes dans la salive
ça a été vu par dodo groupe à
l'international qui montre que la salive
comme l'a montré la chaise et bien un
milieu intéressant pour aller mesurer le
virus et qu'il peut elle peut-être
employés y compris assez précocément
c'est vrai que alexandre a appris le il
a il ya quelques mois on pensait qu'on
ne pouvait pas de détecter le commis de
19 dans la salive 1 c'est bien cela
alors en effet on va dire que au départ
on a vraiment commencé par le
prélèvement nasopharyngé je dirais que
c'était un petit peu l'état actuel des
choses et c'était un peu la façon dont
les tests se faisait en biologie nous de
notre côté avec franck très très trop
tôt dans la crise
on a pris le pari de la salive notamment
sur ce constat paraît terriblement
simple qui est c'est un virus qui se
transmet notamment par les postillons
donc nous avons voulu aller voir s'il y
avait du virus dans la salle il est
c'est ce pour quoi nous nous sommes
battus dès le départ alors franck molina
aujourd'hui si je souhaite faire un test
salivaire parce que j'ai des doutes ou
parce que je dois aller prendre un avion
par exemple comment est ce que je peux
faire
aujourd'hui en france et bien c'est pas
très très claires puisque la
préconisation de la chaîne c'est une
première étape
mais aujourd'hui il faut mettre en place
et s et l'hiver sur le terrain et donc
je pense que ça va nécessiter quelques
jours et quelques semaines je suppose
que certains laboratoires en
entendu ces propositions de la chaise
vont maintenant se mettre à ce type de
test et c'est bien aux alexandrins
prions donc c'est bien cela ce sera les
là ce seront les laboratoires qui france
le type de test où on pourra le faire
ailleurs je pense notamment aux
pharmacies ou pourquoi pas chez les
médecins
alors aujourd'hui selon la
réglementation française ça doit passer
par un laboratoire de biologie médicale
ou en laboratoires hospitaliers
pour faire simple il est possible
d'élargir et de changer la
réglementation mais là ça dépend de
monsieur ministre a et en ce qui
concerne le remboursement ce sera donc
le même cas que pour les tests pcr
aujourd'hui je crois que la hs doit
prendre des décisions à ce sujet et donc
spécifiquement pour les tests salivaires
je suppose que c'est des choses qui sont
acquis sont en débat et que aléas les
réponses à ces questions vont revenir
j'espère très vite à pour conclure
franck molina effectivement aujourd'hui
il ya la volonté de désengorger les
laboratoires ces nouveaux tests
salivaires c'est l'une des solutions
selon vous oui pourquoi parce que pour
deux raisons c'est que quelles que
soient leurs performances qui sont de
toute façon acceptable même si elles
peuvent être quelquefois un petit peu
inférieur aux laboratoires
la première chose c'est que la
population l'acceptera très facilement
et donc tous les as symptomatique les
gens qui ne sont pas malades mais qui
veulent se faire tester il ya une
acceptation plus grande et l'autre point
c'est que ces tests peuvent aussi être
réalisées sur le terrain et là on va
aller dans un second point qui est la
récurrence des tests quand on veut
vraiment réduire le taux de propagation
du virus on a besoin de faire des tests
avec des répétitions quelquefois il
suffit pas d attester une fois dans sa
vie pour ne pas être infecté un peu plus
tard et donc il va être important de
penser à une stratégie qui soit à la
fois présente sur le terrain simple
d'emploi et aussi qui permettent une
récurrence des tests parce que sinon on
n'arrivera pas à utiliser les tests pour
enrayer cette épidémie
un dernier mot justement alexandre
apprieu combien de temps pour avoir les
résultats avec un test salivaire
lorsque nous vous avions annoncé au mois
de mai mais semble-t-il c'était une
heure et aujourd'hui avec les
kg de franck nous avons continué les
travaux est donc à présent et demain ce
sera 40 minutes donc c'est extrêmement
rapide et bien merci beaucoup en tout
cas tous les deux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alexandre apprieu je rappelle
que vous êtes pdg de skills elle merci à
vous franck molina directeur de
recherche au cnrs et on reste en france
avec la réforme de l'école nationale de
la magistrature et cette première
annonce le garde des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti propose l'avocate
nathalie rauret à la tête de le nm
une première fois qu'une femme non issus
de la magistrature occuperait ce poste
en france avant d'être nommé ministre de
la justice eric dupond moretti était
favorable à la suppression pure et
simple de l'école nationale de la
magistrature
mais aujourd'hui il souhaite l'ouvrir
davantage et je cite rompre avec des
traditions suranné je vous propose de
mépris pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'école ce directeur sera
une directrice
j'ai proposé à ce poste une femme
d'exception
m nathalie rauret actuel vice bâtonnière
du barreau de paris
elle a prêté serment en 1989 elle a
exercé dans des domaines variés du droit
la richesse de son parcours son
appétence pour l'enseignement son
engagement aux côtés des justiciables
notamment dans le domaine de la
médiation sont les garants des qualités
qu'elle exprimera à la tête de cette
école et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean de maillard de fo magistrats vice
président du tgi paris jean de maillard
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors cette annonce l'école de
magistrature sera vraisemblablement
dirigé par une femme l'avocate nathalie
rohrer on le disait c'est une première
pour la première fois également elle
n'est pas issue de la magistrature
quelle est votre réaction à cette
annonce
j'écoutais c'est un petit peu surprenant
je ne sais pas si par exemple les écoles
du parrot prendrait des magistrats comme
directeur bon il ya un effet d'annonce
évidemment les qualités de cette
personne ne sont pas en cause mais
peut-être qu'il ya un mélange des genres
ou bron qui est dans l'air du temps
disons vous comprenez cette décision
comme une décision nécessaire il faut
effectivement réformer le nm ou
davantage une décision politique
je crois que je crois qu'on cherche à
impressionner par peut-être par un coup
bon quelqu'un dit qu'est ce que ça peu
importe est que ce soit un avocat qui
forment des magistrats plutôt que des
magistrats qu'est ce qu'on demande à
l'école de la magistrature
cette forme et des magistrats qui est-ce
qui connaît le mieux les magistrats ce
sont des magistrats
alors justement il y a deux ans eric
dupond moretti
alors avocat proposé lui dans un livre
de supprimer cette école nationale de la
magistrature
incapable selon lui de former
correctement les futurs magistrats
aujourd'hui il nomme à sa tête une
nouvelle directrice est ce qu'on parle
et on peut parler de revirements en
finalement dans la dans la vision du
garde des sceaux
sans doute la confrontation avec le
principe de réalité et qu est ce que
vous comprenez finalement dans ce regard
du garde des sceaux pourquoi selon lui
il fallait à tout prix
réformer où il faut à tout prix réformer
l'école nationale de la magistrature
qu'est ce qu'il ressort du doigt je
crois que c'est à lui qu'il faudrait
poser la question si on veut réformer la
magistrature
est-ce qu'il faut commencer par réformer
la manière de former des magistrats
ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux commencer par
s'interroger sur ce qu'on demande aux
magistrats
à quoi sert un magistrat c'est peut-être
la première question à se poser
questions aujourd'hui qui se pose
effectivement à quoi sert un magistrat
on ne sait plus très bien qui fait quoi
aujourd'hui au sein de la justice
c'est à dire que surtout la justice on
lui envoie des messages contradictoires
et le plus souvent incompatibles on
voudrait qu'elle soit sévère tout en
l'étant pas qu'elles comprennent sans
comprendre et qu'elle fasse sans faire
et surtout sans avoir les moyens de
faire alors toutes ses demandes
finalement ont pour effet que à la crise
que traverse notre société où on rajoute
une crise qui est celle de l'injustice
mais une crise ne réjouit jamais une
autre crise alors l'atmosphère
effectivement est semble-t-il électrique
avec les syndicats de magistrats depuis
que le garde des sceaux a annoncé
vendredi l'ouverture d'une enquête
administrative contre le parquet
national financier s'est justifié selon
vous alors avant de vous répondre je
vais vous dire que je ne suis je suis
magistrat à la retraite maintenant et
donc je m'exprime plus qu'en mon nom
propre des temps plus non plus
responsable syndical alors le parquet
financier c'est évidemment un petit peu
le déclencheur non pas des problèmes de
la justice mais du débat actuel
le parti financier il faut se souvenir
que il a été créé à la suite de la
sphère cahuzac
on l'a vu comme un progrès de
l'indépendance de la magistrature et de
moyens donnés à la magistrature de
s'intéresser
à des problèmes qui aujourd'hui sont des
problèmes majeurs et de société on peut
aussi être plus réservé sur le parquet
national financier parce que on a créé
ce parc national financier d'une façon
très jacobine très centralisé tellement
centralisée qu' il n'y a que 1 ou 2
magistrats
c'est à dire le le procureur national
financier est peut-être un de ses
adjoints ou deux qui divisent je verrai
véritablement les poursuites et
centralise toutes ses poursuites
on l'a vu avec la sphère fillon une très
grande réactivité qui a d'ailleurs
étonné parce que la justice souvent
n'est pas aussi rapide dans une période
où je dirais il avait une tradition
républicaine qui valait ce qu'elles
valaient mais qui a été foulée aux pieds
à cette occasion là qui la tradition
républicaine étant que pendant les
élections il y avait 10 ans non pas une
trêve judiciaire mais que la justice ne
m'étais pas l'accélérateur sur les
affaires alors il ya eu des soupçons et
ces soupçons ont été bien confirmée par
la procureur de l'époque madame houlette
qui ensuite a essayé de se rétracter à
saint malo maladroitement et tout ceci
ne fait qu'ajouter à la confusion et la
réponse qui est donnée aujourd'hui par
est quand même extrêmement faible par
rapport ce que l'on dit depuis des
décennies sur l'état de dépendance de la
justice à l'égard du pouvoir politique
et pas simplement du parquet alors
justement pour conclure aujourd'hui
quelles sont selon vous les grands
chantiers à mener aujourd'hui pour la
justice il faut parler au conditionnel
parce qu'on sait que ces chantiers ne
seront pas ouverts
il faudrait réfléchir justement non pas
au statut du parquet vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs politiques mais à cette machine
judiciaire qui est une sorte de deux
bras armé de l'état ce qui donne au jour
est difficilement concevable le la
justice doit être indépendante ou non
pas parce que le pouvoir politique a
encore une capacité de nuisance mais
parce que la justice a besoin d'être
intégré dans la société n'ont pas non
pas pour s'y dissoudre mais pour
comprendre pour connaître et comprendre
une société qui est en entrée rapide
évolution et le centralisme jacobin n'a
jamais été un moyen de s'adapter
rapidement et là aujourd'hui on voit que
rien n'est fait pour permettre à la
justice d'avoir les moyens dont elle
doit disposer pour pour agir et donc les
moyens de son indépendance structurelle
ils n'ont pas simplement la justice
l'indépendance des individus merci
beaucoup jean de maillard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes magistrat syndicaliste à la
retraite et vice président du tgi paris
et dans quelques instants nous parlerons
du magny qui se dote d'un président de
transition l'ex ministre de la défense
ben dhaou a été désigné par un comité
mis en place par la junte au pouvoir
depuis le putsch du
8 août il doit exercer sa fonction
pendant plusieurs mois avant un retour
des civils au pouvoir
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire la france
c'est ainsi que de polichinelle je ne
pourrais pas qu'il appartiendra prince
de régler des problèmes entre y voir le
bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'imprimer leurs peuples il faut
demander au régime ivoiris de faire en
sorte d n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions l'attention et la tôle où vous
demander un report du scrutin prévu le
31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les circonstances pareilles c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans ses menus
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
catholique et féministe facilement il y
à un discrédit de principes posés sur le
mot féministe alors que c'est simplement
la reconnaissance de son existence
d'être féminin est ce que vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an tu reçois
masculin dans l'église
bien sûr qu'il y à nantes reçoit
masculine et un plafond de verre qui
empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église
elles ne sont jamais autonomes dans leur
dans leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière donc il est
temps il est temps de dire que l'église
ne peut pas fonctionner sur un seul de
ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une seule
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change
la rivière tout beau et chaud au delà du
cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tchoum la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française au mali
l'ex ministre de la défense bat and how
désigné président de transition
l annonce a été faite cet après midi à
la télévision nationale par le chef de
la junte militaire le colonel assis
meego ita le nouveau président est censé
officiers officiers comme chef d'état
pendant plusieurs mois avant un retour
des civils au pouvoir
cette nomination intervient à la veille
de l'ultimatum de la cédéao
l'instance ouest africaine exigeait
pourtant sans délai des dirigeants issus
de la société civile et pour en parler
nous sommes avec ali tounkara sociologue
directeur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sahel
est avec vous luis que mailloux
président du club de l'information
africaine c'est notre décryptage
[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer c'est donc un colonel major
qui sera président de transition
or c'était clair la cedeao demandait un
profil civil alors comment comprendre
cette nomination pourquoi aujourd'hui un
profil militaire est devenu acceptable
luis cailloux je rêve depuis le début
les militaires n'en a fait n'ont pas
fait de non pas fait de mystère sur le
fait qu'il souhaitait eux-mêmes conduire
la transition jusqu'aux prochaines
élections qui permettront d'avoir un
président élu sur une base démocratique
mais je pense que de l'autre côté aussi
il n'ya pas y'a pas considérer que dans
les pays africains aujourd'hui plus
qu'ailleurs
quand il ya un conflit social où quand
il ya une rébellion armée qui se
soulèvent contre un gouvernement on est
obligé de passer par des règlements
aussi rigide compte ce que la cedeao est
en train d'imposer aujourd'hui c'est à
dire un blocus sans aucune analyse fine
de la situation je pense qu'on en est
arrivé aujourd'hui à une position quasi
mediène mais dans laquelle les
militaires ont gardé la main jusqu'au
bout du processus pour désigner
quelqu'un à qui ils font confiance
auquel les militaires n'auront pas du
mal à obéir puisqu'il est issu de
laurent
et qu'il n'est plus aujourd'hui dans les
rangs simplement parce qu'il a pris sa
retraite dont je pense que quelque part
la cedeao est à moitié satisfait les
militaires sont à moitié satisfait mais
ce qui va compter le plus c'est que
cette transition produisent les
résultats qu'on en attend c'est à dire
un assainissement de la vie politique
qui était devenu très délétère au mali
et qui aujourd'hui a besoin d'un
véritable coup de balai pour reprendre
un processus aussi vertueux que celui
qui avait suivi le départ de amadou
toumani touré quand il a fait le premier
coup d'état qui l'a ilham la main ou le
pouvoir aux civils et qu'il a été réélu
par la suite allait tounkara que ces
tombes ce président de transition est ce
que c'est une figure connue
est ce que c'est la personne idoine
finalement pour assurer cette transition
de sa nomination en effet le dimanche
comme ans intéresse aux différents
commentaires faits par des maliens qui
soit l'un des leurs ou même territoire
clément ne posions dit un homme un peu
traîné malien tout à la personne c'est
imad et cnda world et quelques mots
essentiels à la meinau c'est quand même
plus la cedeao n'était pas dé facto
poser assez calé choix soit également
porté sur ses supérieurs avec ce qu'il
est car quand on rigole un peu sa
trajectoire
actuellement elle suscite admiration
abnégation voix soul et légitimité est
ce qui fait qu sur ledit les choix des
missiles dawa beaucoup des manières est
un choix judicieux et mais surtout
surtout les fêtes et des habitats désert
de son père qui le tenait par les
légendes liées à l'islamisation du bien
beaucoup d'émoi nier c'est les connais
ce sentiment lui vous confirmez
aujourd'hui le peuple malien se
satisfait de ce consensus
je pense qu'il se sait ce qui fait
surtout du fait que ce choix ne va pas
être retoquée par les chefs d'état de la
cedeao c'était ça la plus grande
crenn je crois de la part des
populations maliennes
parce que en soit il ya une vraie
défiance vis-à-vis de la cedeao qui
aujourd'hui présenté comme un club de
chefs d'état qui se défendent entre eux
et quand on voit la manière dont les
chefs d'état de la cedeao se sont
comportés au mali ou aux premières
heures du coup d'état
voir pendant que le mouvement m5 lfp
battait le pavé pour demander d'abord la
démission du chef de l'état ibrahim
boubacar keita puis celui de son premier
ministre
on a l'impression que pendant cette
période-là la cedeao avaient fait bloc
avec le gouvernement malien plus qu'il
ne prenait fait et cause pour les
populations
donc aujourd'hui les populations
auraient pu être sanctionné si jamais
les militaires avaient pris une attitude
radicale dans laquelle ils imposaient un
militaire de rang qui n'a pas pris sa
retraite
heureusement pour tout le monde ce choix
a porté de façon je dirais presque mali
sur un militaire à la retraite qui
accepte et à la fois par les militaires
par la société civile et je l'espère par
la classe politique dont c'est presque
rouge de soulagement pour la population
qui va voir passer les sanctions qui
était qui pesait l'amener à l'épée de
damoclès des sanctions qui pesait sur sa
tête alors le gouvernement de transition
est prévue pour 18 mois 18 mois est ce
que c'est une perspective réaliste ali
tounkara alors que polygone tous les
lots cepandant naturellement ayez 18
mois sont tout à fait compréhensibles
aux défis qui attendent quand même à
cette transition ne le mal que hbo ou
des personnalités personnes militaires
eux-mêmes aux politiques sont notamment
cités dans la posture liés elle écrit
personnalités ont fait l'objet des
particules thibault seul et bezzaz et où
le cac intestins kéita et dans do
beaucoup de maliens
la tradition qui nobel n'a afin
d'intégrer tout s'est passé en bas de la
nuque d'un sourire de sécurité de la
protection des navires cette offre est
ému et satisfait les attentes qu'on
avait calé le canadien et notamment
celle des populations vivant à ces
différends politiques françois clément
aujourd'hui beaucoup de maliens tous
qu'elle était humain son nom est exagéré
et derrière c'est pas poli la cedh avait
finalement sont tous également né s'est
pas attardé sur la temporalité aux
dégâts des filles kata kata de match
parce que je ne peux pas coutume à
l'aller sort selon malick tall et
d'évoquer notamment senecé liés à la
nomination financière l'autre
l'équipement l'audition de l'ex
d'instinct logiquement militaires même
l'achat la seor sans compter toutes ces
batteries collectives auxquelles son
département légal l'état font l'objet
donc tous hélas aujourd'hui les surcoûts
allemagne est effectivement avec une
tradition déjà paré no more type ltd
très intègre une antiquité des blue
bulls
donc ce n'est pas tragique par l'école
militaire noir à ses différentes
fonctions exercées notamment à son
passage du département de la défense et
de la sécurité actuellement tous et le
jeudi à paris met au point les cieux et
surtout surtout et devant tous ces
dossiers pendants qui nous lisent mon
papier du ttp pour les jo liés à des
accointances avec cet acteur josip est
concerné par ce parti politique avec
quelqu'un du pays la donne change et les
18 mois et bâle est chargé des maliens
comme moi en tant qu équipe est à cette
condition est d'amorcer si vous voulez
et retrait d'éjecter les balles d'un
visuel des bêtes de somme est capable
les façades ici déficit public justement
louis keumayou pour arriver vers un
pouvoir civil un pouvoir souvent est-ce
que brandao va devoir travailler avec
les dirigeants de ses pays voisins de la
cedeao oui il est obligé en quelque
sorte de travailler avec déjà que ce
sont eux qui ont imposé que son profil
soit relativement celui qui était
attendu
de l'autre côté il faut aussi penser
qu'après la transition
il faudrait que la vie politique normale
reprenne et que les vrais débats
politiques soient posées il ya un débat
de fond qui n'a pas encore été posée qui
est celui du renouvellement de la classe
politique
aujourd'hui la l'élite politique
malienne et constitue presque d'un seul
parti politique celui qui a permis le
renversement de moussa traoré dans les
années 90
tous ces leaders politiques qu'ils
soient de l'opposition ou de la majorité
en sont issus donc ça fait que la
nécessité de renouveler la classe
politique est aujourd'hui là il ya un
deuxième enjeu qui est celui de la
réconciliation entre les manières parce
que le dossier sur lequel ybrig aux
banques grecques
boubacar kéïta pardon était attendue et
sur lequel il a le plus lamentablement
échoué celui de reconquérir le nord du
pays non seulement et n'a pas réussi à
reconquérir l'honore mais en plus il a
perdu le centre également
donc c'est plus de deux tiers du
territoire qui ne sont plus sous le
contrôle de l'autorité de l'état
et c'est également ce terrorisme qui est
en train de gangréner non plus seulement
le mali comme au début mais également
les pays voisins dont qu'il est
nécessaire pour lui de travailler déjà
avec les pays du g5 celle ensuite de
travail avec la france des nations unies
et les pays de la cedeao pour trouver
une solution à cette crise qui reste
très importante mais rappelons quand
même que il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'élire un président au terme de la
transition mais de reprendre une vie
politique qui a été plus que chaotique
depuis que amadou toumani touré a été
renversée dans les années 2000
et que tout cela est un véritable
chantier pour lequel si le président
malien a l'impression qu'il peut
travailler tout seul il se trompe il a
besoin aujourd'hui de réancrer le mali
comme un vrai partenaire au sein du g5
celle au sein de la cd aux voix au sein
de l'union africaine pour trouver des
solutions africaines aux problèmes du
manet allait tout car à louis keumayou
vient de nous parler des relations avec
la france on sait que la france
intervient dans la région avec
l'opération barkan avec ce nouveau
président de transition à quelle
relation on peut s'attendre entre la
france et le mali dans les dents les
jours les mois qui viennent à coquelles
et les potes président kita et la
commodité klein ses intentions le sans
dénigrer les distances accords qui lient
les manières avec ses partenaires mais
d'aller lui même temps c'est une
militaire aujourd'hui les 40 porté par
des sondages
s'agissant du volet majeur lolita et au
tour canon également le coup d'état
elles sont aussi des différents 4 bella
swan il est loin cette immense
d'officiers militaires lors les
l'importance des jus la france d'arles
catholique contrôle exceptionnel mais
c'est tout de suite également à cause de
la même arène la commune belge ne
s'était pas produit les formations au
niveau d'une équipe manque et même sur
toute la famille transmets mes chances
que ces compétences atteindra les
semaines et les mois à venir
c'est dans une redéfinition la
cartographie serriculteurs un des duos
l'avantagé par la face pas d'enfant
c'est beaucoup de voix se font entendre
effectivement cette enseigne pas
qu'elles ont elles évolué et pas de
façon coopérative avec l'armée régulière
malienne n'a donc je pense que cela va
être pile soulever
à cette tradition et domine également le
sont légales aussi la mort des forces
onusiennes entente est aujourd'hui sous
le territoire malien
et il voit un combien les sécurités
saint-aignan l'appeller par ces
messieurs manuelle ou bien des raisons
dit maudit maquilleuse nouveaux outils
une bonne partie 10 ans notamment dans
les zones mopti et sailor aussi de ces
boues seul indice une boucle au but en
or clair l'autre c'est christ exposée la
foire par l'armée malienne à ce
partenariat les pas innovants adaptés
aux exigences sécuritaires qu'on observe
c'est donc les sept otages sur nouveau
mal-aimé temps pose est bien fondé de la
passion française m'a vite mais les
victoires il va s'efforcer à faire
insulte que cette estimation français
mené de l'esa et de façon générale de
soi des jeunes mais en tout cas à défaut
d'être définies par les pays
bénéficiaires dans le mode hic est que
cette information soit quand même à la
limite contrôler si vous voulez garder
tous les goûts et qu il y ait à la suite
des graves
des avions français et c'est là démontre
combien elle ne sera une volée relâche
militaires les également s'il ne mène
pas des maliens et d'édiction sont m81
un beau allait venir
l'epita tracé elle notamment dans les
régions du nord a transmis la définition
de l'offre sécurité voient les
occupations
mais cette condition et il faut le laver
les gamins lesieu laquelle le président
était allé à vis d'une gare il nous
reste quelques secondes on va peut être
laisser le mot de la fin à louis
keumayou louis keumayou à quoi est-ce
que vous allez être attentif en quelques
mots dans les heures les jours qui vont
venir
je pense que ce à quoi on doit être plus
attentifs aujourd'hui c'est la capacité
pour les
les militaires qui enfin pour la
transition de nettoyer les écuries
d'augias pour pemettre nouveau départ au
niveau de la scène politique malienne
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
alain au terme de la transition
on devrait mettre l'accent à la fois sur
le sécurité mais surtout sur les
questions de développement
les questions économiques les questions
sociales qui aujourd'hui sont le parent
pauvre de ce combat le mal et n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent ils en dépensent
beaucoup pour les militaires même si
c'est détourné et il est important que
les populations aussi s'y retrouve que
ce soit sur le plan du développement du
recrutement la lutte contre le chômage
et puis l'intégration dans le tissu
économique national pour les jeunes
merci en tout cas à tous les deux nous
avoir aidés à décrypter la situation
aujourd'hui au mali avec nous donc ali
tounkara merci je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sahel et merci également à vous louis
keumayou je rappelle que vous êtes
président du club de l'information
africaine à la situation en biélorussie
ya à présent malgré l'appel de
l'opposante
svetlana tirano sky à l'union européenne
n'a pas réussi à se mettre d'accord pour
imposer des sanctions à l'encontre de la
biélorussie
réunis aujourd'hui à bruxelles les
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne ont rencontré lundi
la figure de proue de l'opposition bien
bélarus
malgré la pression du chef de la
diplomatie allemande
et comme as plusieurs capitales
européennes estime toutefois que cibler
le président biélorusse n'aidera pas la
tentative de médiation demandé à
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe les ministres ont
discuté de la question des sanctions est
bien qu'il y ait une volonté claire
d'adopter ces sanctions il n'a pas été
possible de le faire aujourd'hui parce
que l'unanimité requise n'a pas été
atteinte
[Musique]
la question devrait être examiné par les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement lors du
conseil européen qui se tiendra plus
tard dans la semaine afin de dégager des
orientations politiques
la nouvelle réunion des 27 au sujet de
la biélorussie l'union européenne qui
continue donc de faire pression sur
alexandre lukashenko le président
biélorusse parle d'ingérence mathilde
euros magnan et cléricaux cette
intervention a provoqué la colère de la
biélorussie vendredi svetlana tirs à 9
sky à la nouvelle pasionaria de
l'opposition biélorusse est apparu lors
d'une réunion au conseil des droits de
l'homme des nations unies
une invitation à l'initiative des
diplomates européens loin d'être au goût
de minsk et de moscou il juge cette
intervention contraires au règlement du
conseil des droits de l'homme et il voit
une forme d'ingérence dans les affaires
internes biélorusse la participation de
tirano sky à la réunion des ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'ue est une
ingérence ouvertes dans les affaires de
la biélorussie minsk a porté ses
positions à l'attention des diplomates
européens
le flirt des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'ue eux avec la
représentante autoproclamé de
l'opposition biélorusse et son
invitation à bruxelles pour communiquer
fait partie intégrante d'un scénario d'
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
de la biélorussie il s'agit d'une
violation directe des normes
fondamentales de la charte des nations
unies et des principes de l'acte final
d'helsinki de la csc eux sous couvert de
préoccupations fictives pour les
citoyens biélorusses
l'union européenne tente en fait de
décider à leur place comment ils doivent
vivre l'union européenne prend
clairement partie dans ce dossier le
chef de la diplomatie européenne josep
borrell insiste pour que de nouvelles
élections se tiennent à nouveau
aujourd'hui nous allons discuter de la
manière dont nous pouvons soutenir la
population et revoir nos relations avec
le gouvernement biélorusse puisque nous
ne reconnaissons pas alexandre
loukachenko comme président légitime de
la biélorussie est légitime et nous
sommes vraiment impressionnés par le
courage et la persévérance du peuple
biélorusse en particulier les femmes qui
font preuve d'un réel sens de leadership
enfin permettez moi de souligner que
nous soutiendrons le dialogue national
inclusif et les droits du peuple à des
élections libres et équitables
une nouvelle prise de position et de
potentiel sanction qui hérite le
président biélorusse les pays européens
harcèle la biélorussie nous pouvons
fermer la frontière trop près de brest
et de grodno et après comment les
allemands iron steel en chine
comment les marchandises seront elles
transporté qui peuvent traverser les
frontières dans le sud ou dans le nord
mais si nous concluons un accord avec la
russie
si nous y arriverons aucun des grands
dirigeants à la tête des états européens
ne m'arrêtera l'accueil réservé à
svetlana tirano sky à ce lundi à
bruxelles apparaît aux yeux de minsk
comme une ultime provocation peu propice
à une résolution de la crise et c'est la
fin de cette émission on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité rester avec nous
sur rt france a tout de suite
[Musique]
vous croyez qu'avec cette candidature du
pdc y votre parti reste crédible partir
du moment où le président bédié revenir
dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner cette
élection et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre ou les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même je
me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien que difficiles qui avait
une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour
nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
après je crois que le groupe d'avants il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors par mois elle
s'était d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde dames
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique ici on écoute
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si seul interdit d'interdire
vous croyez qu'avec cette candidature du
pdc y votre parti reste crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir icône
aux métiers revient de course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de direction nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir planier ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près des warnings
[Musique]
on doit le combattre
vous avez découvert que l'imagerie
médicale qui était le coeur de votre
métier avait une dimension artistique me
suis aperçu que c'était l'art qui
faisait avancer la science et la science
qui faisait avancer là l'image est belle
mais mais en général le mal qu'elle
révèle il est terrifiant au moment du
coc vite quand j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
3d de virton life a pour mentor axe boat
et pour le virus j'ai pu suivre son
évolution comme henry ça s'aggravait ou
au contraire comment ça s'évacue et
quand on a découvert le kobe dansait on
sait comment ils et comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal les mèches du mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
catholique et féministe facilement il y
à un discrédit de principes posés sur le
mot féministe alors que c'est simplement
la reconnaissance de son existence
d'être faits mineurs est ce que vous
diriez qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an tu
reçois masculin dans l'église
bien sûr qu'il y à nantes reçoit metz
que la fim et un plafond de verre qui
empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église d elles
ne sont jamais autonomes dans leur dans
leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière donc